David Boder: [In Russian] Как Ваша фамилия?
Leon Shachnovski: Моя фамилия Шахновский.
David Boder: Скажите, а Ваше имя-отчество, господин Шахновский?
Leon Shachnovski: Моё имя и отчество [пауза] Леон Моисеевич.
David Boder: Леон Моисеевич. Ну, хорошо, Леон Моисеевич. Мы сегодня тут в Париже, это 29го июля, день...эээ...Мирной конференции. Скажите, Леон Моисеевич, когда Вы уехали из России?
Leon Shachnovski: Я уже очень давно уехал из России. Из России я уехал в 41ом году.
David Boder: Ну, это не очень давно! Вы, значит, уехали из Советской России или?
Leon Shachnovski: Да, из Советской Рос...покинул Советскую Россию.
David Boder: Эээ...Россия была уже во время войны тогда?
Leon Shachnovski: Это было...да...это было уже начало. Да, 22го июня началась война, и нас немцы тогда быстро захватили Ковно, в течение двух дней они захватили нас и депортировали в Германию.
David Boder: Ну, так что Вы не убежали из России?
Leon Shachnovski: Нет, я не убежал из России.
David Boder: Ага.
Leon Shachnovski: Меня...меня насильно немцы депортировали.
Leon Shachnovski: В то время я работал в концентрационных лагерях различных, шатался по Германии, покуда нас американцы в 45 году 27 апреля не освободили.
David Boder: Ага. Ну, вот начните-ка немножко по порядку. Немцы взяли Ковно, и Вас что? За...арестовали, взяли в плен.
Leon Shachnovski: Дело вот в чём как было. Нем...До того, значит...война началась [пауза] война началась 22го июня, это было с воскресенья на по...нет, это было с субботы на воскресенье.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: В воскресенье после обеда и главным образом в понедельник до обеда литовские партизаны, которые сражались на стороне немцев, захватили Ковно. До того, как немцы вв...[пауза] как немцы в Ко...вошли в Ковно. Эти ж самые литовские партизаны преследовали всех отступающих красноармейцев и стреляли по ним.
Leon Shachnovski: Немцы [пауза] только появились во вторник. И так они...мы остались в городе до 15го августа. 15 августа был приказ, что мы все должны собраться...
David Boder: Кто это мы?
Leon Shachnovski: Мы – все живущие евреи в городе Ковне должны таковой город покинуть, они нам оцепили один район и...и переселили нас в этот район.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: Этот район назывался гетто. Мы находились в этом гетто. Я лично был сразу же, в первые месяцы, депортирован с еще другими в Германию.
David Boder: Ага. Кого же они депортировали?
Leon Shachnovski: Это была маленькая группа людей – 550 человек, большинство погибло. Сохранилось, по всей вероятности, всего несколько человек из тех, которых нас депортировали я бы до сегодняшнего дня никого не видал, потому что нас потом разместили по отдельным лагерям. Я потом случайно попал сюда, в Дахау – это под Мюнхеном – и с Дахау перешел потом еще в Аугсбург. Последний мой лагерь это был в Аугсбурге – я работал у мессершмита, на заводе аэропланов. И там нас...
David Boder: Да.
Leon Shachnovski: . . . , значит, эти американцы освободили.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво]
Leon Shachnovski: Все, что я пережил за это время, невозможно так кра...коротко рассказать. Я только могу рассказать, что я очень пострадал, так как я потерял всё свое семейство. Отца и мать они в 41ом году расстреляли, немцы. На моих глазах, в 1941 году, 28 октября, на моих глазах.
David Boder: Как же это было? В Ковне?
Leon Shachnovski: Это было еще, когда мы были в гетто. Они часть людей из гетто вывели. Тогда они...нас было приблизительно 30 000 человек, они 12 000 человек выбрали из гетто, и тут же недалеко от нашего гетто расстреляли из пулемёта, заставив раньше их раздеться, снять одёжды и отдать одёжду.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: [Пауза] и...и ещё стреляли.
Leon Shachnovski: Мы почти что все видали всю эту так называемую акцию, которую они произвели.
David Boder: [Пауза] Что ж, в один день расстреляли сразу 12 000 человек?
Leon Shachnovski: 12 000 человек расстреляли в течение поч...одного дня.
David Boder: И кто же их похоронил?
Leon Shachnovski: Были приготовлены уже заранее ямы вырытые. Они стояли около ям и падали в ямы, и лежали на ямах друг на друге и...и, значит, патрули литовские и американские ходили и, если кто-нибудь еще дышал и жил, то их приканчивали тут же из револьвера.
David Boder: Что Вы говорите – американские патрули?!
Leon Shachnovski: То есть, извините, пожалуйста, я думал немецкие патрули! [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Ага, это ничего. Вы оговорились. Теперь скажите, остальных, значит, оставили в живых?
Leon Shachnovski: Остальных оставили в живых. И на следующий день все, как ни в чем не бывало, должны были пойти на работу и продолжать свою повседневную работу.
David Boder: А что же они работали там? Что Вы работали?
Leon Shachnovski: Мы работали следующее: нас отправляли группами на всевозможные работы. Самая большая группа это была в 1000 человек, которая ходила на аэродромные работы. Ковенский аэродром немцы перестраивали, хотели перестроить и сделать из него самым модный аэродром. Кроме того, как рассказывали, там должна была быть школа для пилотов так называемых штурцкапффлюгцойге. И вот мы на этом аэродроме работали: русские пленные и мы. Русские пленные находились в отчаянных условиях, гораздо лучше, чем мы. С ними абсолютно не считались как с людьми.
David Boder: Гораздо хуже?
Leon Shachnovski: Гораздо хуже. [Неразборчиво]
David Boder: Да, это ничего.
Leon Shachnovski: Гора...извините, я неправильно сказал – это гораздо хуже. В хужих условиях, чем мы. Они жили под навесом, совершенно открыто.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: Под...под навесом совершенно открыто. Мыться им не было разрешено, получали они к обеду и, очевидно, к ужину, я не видал этого, видал только обед, какую-то черную бурду и кусочек хлеба. Это всё, что они получали. Обращение с ними было нечеловеческое. За каждое движение, за каждое слово их немилосердно били. Если бывали больные, которые не могли правильно ходить или двигаться, как не...немцам хотелось, так их же тут же на месте добивали до смерти палками. Мы...невозможно было смотреть на это обращение [говорит с дрожью в голосе].
David Boder: Что [неразборчиво] А оттуда, значит, Вы потом были отправлены...
Leon Shachnovski: Я лично попал в Германию, проделал много лагерей различных...
David Boder: Что значит «попал»? Вас отправили [неразборчиво]?
Leon Shachnovski: Отправили в Германию.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: Депортировали в Германию.
David Boder: Так. И потом повезли куда?
Leon Shachnovski: Раньше всего повезли нас в Штутхоф. Это под Данцигом лагерь.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: Оттуда я попал в Дахау. В Дахау было очень много различных так называемых аусенлагерунг, в которых я тоже работал.
David Boder: А что это такое—«аусенлагерунг»?
Leon Shachnovski: Сам концентрационный лагерь имеет еще од...один...специальные отделения различных других лагерей. Это есть, предположим, что какая-нибудь фабрика или какое-нибудь строительство, находится в этой же местности, где находится самый главный лагерь. Тогда...для того, чтобы отправить туда людей на работу, устраивают маленькие лагери недалеко, в трех, четырех или десяти километрах от этой данной фабрики или от этого данного строительства. Эти люди тогда живут в этих маленьких лагерях и идут на строительство. На работы, на строительство или на фабрики.
David Boder: А скажите, эээ..., кормили...эээ..., как кормили людей там? Тех, которые работали.
Leon Shachnovski: Кормили совершенно различно. [Пауза] Мы получали утром кофе. Так называемый кофе, потому что это не было настоящее, была какая-то черная бурда.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: Кром...к обеду мы получали [пауза] три четверти литра сваренного какого-нибудь супа.
Leon Shachnovski: Он был иногда с картошкой, иногда с капустой, иногда с чем-нибудь другим. Мяса почти что там никогда не было. [Пауза] Вечером мы получа...могли получить немного кофе, так на...тоже какой-то черной бурды. К этому мы получали хлеб. Это...порции хлеба были различно: они...первые, значит, первые получали 500гр хлеба и доходило до 150гр хлеба в день – совершенно различно.
David Boder: [Пауза] Так. И где Вы работали? Над чем Вы работали?
Leon Shachnovski: Я лично...я лично как специалист-техник старался все время работать в каких-нибудь мастерских. Этим я сохранил свою жизнь, то что я мог, зная и как известное ремесло, время от времени работать в мастерских. В мастерских работа была тем легче, что она находилась под навесом, она не была на открытом воздухе [кашляет], в то время как большинство должны были работать с лопатой или с киркой или с чем-нибудь другим на открытом воздухе при любой погоде: в снегу, в дождь, и...вьюгу и тому подобное. Многие работали также у бетонных работ и тут же попадали в бетон, были заживо погребены в этот бетон и входили...и потом были растерты машинами и входили, значит...входили как составная часть бетона для постройки многих зданий, фундаментов и тому подобных вещей.
David Boder: Как же они попадали в бетон? Каким...
Leon Shachnovski: А их просто...их сбрасывали в ямы, в машины. Я лично не видал сам, так что точно указать не могу, но я знаю о таких фактах, когда их просто сбрасывали, бросали...эээ...там, где приготовлялся бетон, в этих машинах, и они были вместе с бет...со всеми камнями, с бетоном раскрошены на куски.
David Boder: Так, это, значит, было в Дахау. И как долго Вы были в Дахау?
Leon Shachnovski: [пауза] Я был в Дахау от 42 года до 45, потому что все остальные лагери, даже в том, где я был в Аугсбурге, в мессершмите – это все входило под Дахау, хотя это было далеко от Дахау, но это числилось все отделение Дахау.
David Boder: Так как, Вы ездили каждый день на работу?
Leon Shachnovski: Нет, я раньше уже объяснил, что мы находились в известных других помещениях, бараках, которые были построены недалеко от места работы.
David Boder: Ага! Но это было под властью...
Leon Shachnovski: Это все под властью...мы респектировали из Дахау, мы были все регистрированы в Дахау, у меня все документы имеются из...лагеря Дахау
David Boder: . . . Дахау. А скажите, Вам платили что-нибудь за работу?
Leon Shachnovski: Нам ничего не платили.
David Boder: Но я видел, например, в Штатах какие-то...деньги концентрационных лагерей.
Leon Shachnovski: Это были деньги, да. Это были деньги концентрационных лагерей. Совершенно правильно. Это...
David Boder: Да.
Leon Shachnovski: . . . арийские. Мы, евреи, этого не получали. Ну, а арийцы имели право на какие-то премии, и когда они получали эти премии, они получали какие-то монеты.
David Boder: Так.
Leon Shachnovski: И этими монетами они могли в кантинах, которые были в лагерях, себе что-нибудь купить. Мы этими преимуществами не пользовались, так что я ничего точного об этом не могу сказать. Кроме того, не в лагерях, а в гетто были...эээ...деньги. Скажем, гетто Терезиенштат имело свои деньги.
David Boder: [Неразборчиво, очень тихо] А из Дахау Вы попали куда? Вы в Дахау были до самого освобождения?
Leon Shachnovski: Я из Дахау попал в Аугсбург и работал у мессершмита, как я раньше сказал Вам.
David Boder: Да.
Leon Shachnovski: Но мессершмит тоже был лагерем от...лагерем Дахау, числился тоже в Дахау, хотя это находилось от Дахау приблизительно в 70км.
David Boder: Ну...эээ...я Вам очень благодарен [неразборчиво, Шахновский что-то тихо говорит]. Да, это оговорки. И...спасибо. Я думаю, что если мне дают проезд, я Вас найду. Вы где? В Мюнхене?
Leon Shachnovski: В Мюнхене.
David Boder: Хорошо. Теперь...